yep back on the couch yeah Dan will be
moderating that debate he spent four
decades in federal government but former
kovitz are Anthony fauci raising
eyebrows this news disclosures reveal
he's worth more than an 11 million
dollars by the time he left this is
crazy and two million of it was
reportedly made since the pandemic alone
outkick founder clay Travis is here to
react how did he make all this money
clay
well I think he was first of all happy
birthday Ainsley uh second I think he
was the highest paid federal employee
yeah at the time that he stepped down
right so the way he made all this money
is from yours and mines and everybody
else out there uh taxpayer dollars and
then I guarantee you I don't know that
they've fully published it but whatever
dollars he's gonna get for his Memoirs
or his uh or his book that he's writing
I'm sure is going to be wildly in excess
of how much it will actually sell but
this is how you get paid if you are a
left-wing activist masquerading as a
bipartisan Health advisor and this is
why I think when hopefully we have a
Republican president in 2024 there has
to be a reckoning for the lies that Dr
fauci told Congress under oath Rand Paul
and others Senator Rand Paul and others
have talked a great deal about this uh
and and this is where I think we need to
go after him aggressively you you're
right he actually made more than the
president of the United States but clay
maybe he's just a really Savvy investor
remember back in the 70s when Hillary
Clinton took what was it a thousand
dollars and invested in cattle futures
and ten months later she had a hundred
thousand
yeah maybe he's just really good at
timing for instance maybe he bought
moderna and Pfizer stock before he knew
that Joe Biden was going to try and
mandate that every human on the planet
use them right I mean probably just a
coincidence in that kind of thing but it
look the the reality is fauci is a fraud
I think every day more Americans know it
and become aware of it uh and the fact
that the CDC is still trying to get
six-month-olds to get the new coveted
booster shot is I think just absolutely
Reckless and ridiculous
not illegal immigrants they don't need
anything just let them in doesn't matter
all right clay good luck with buck today
thank you and you can check out okay
good morning on alkick.com I'm Steve
Ducey I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis